♪ ♪ ♪
- Imaginez le privilège de
visiter le temple de la renommée
du hockey à Moscou et de croiser
ses légendes en chair et en os,
comme Vladislav Tretiak.
Tretiak, Boris Mikhaïlov,
Alexander Yakushev, ils sont
les gardiens d'un pan
spectaculaire de l'histoire.
Même pour l'ambassadrice
du Canada en Russie,
les rencontrer est surréel.
Un tour de force du cinéaste
canadien Robbie Hart, qui rêve,
depuis des années, d'un grand
documentaire pour souligner
les 50 ans, l'an prochain,
de la série qui a révolutionné
le sport.
ROBBIE HART, documentariste
- Faire un film qui va unir
toutes les générations.
Il y a les générations
qui ont vécu ça, mais il y a
une génération de Canadiens
qui ne connaissent pas bien,
ou qui connaissent rien de 1972.
- Voilà la mise au jeu.
- Huit matchs disputés en pleine
guerre froide pour le titre de
la meilleure nation sur glace.
"C'est un honneur de participer
à ce film," dit Tretiak.
"Parce que c'est l'histoire
du hockey russe, celle du vôtre.
Les Canadiens et les plus jeunes
doivent connaître les héros qui
en ont été les précurseurs."
Le grand journaliste sportif
russe Vsevolod Kukushkin
se souvient de la victoire
des soviétiques lors du
tout premier match à Montréal.
- C'était comme un eye-opener.
Ça créait, mais... On pensait
être les seuls à jouer notre
sport national. Ah! tabarnak!
- Tout le monde a compris,
ce jour-là, que le hockey
ne serait plus jamais le même.
"Les Canadiens étaient plus
agressifs, plus brusques, alors
que, nous, les Soviétiques,
on jouait avec une grande
discipline."
"C'était la fusion
de deux écoles", dit-il.
- Aujourd'hui, la Ligue
nationale et 50 % canadiens.
En 72, c'était 90 %.
Donc, c'est une histoire
beaucoup plus large que
juste simplement qui a gagné
le match de hockey.
- Et le but de Henderson!
- Bien que le but gagnant
de Paul Henderson, à 39 secondes
de la fin du dernier match
de la série, demeure l'un des
moments les plus emblématiques
de l'histoire du sport.
- Et il faut savoir reconnaître
que l'équipe soviétique était
un adversaire redoutable.
- Le Canada aura aussi découvert
en Tretiak un bon perdant
et un grand charmant gaillard.
L'ancien diplomate Gary Smith
était un des architectes
de la série de 1972.
Son témoignage est essentiel
pour comprendre l'audace
d'une telle entreprise
à l'époque où l'URSS, avec la
menace d'une guerre nucléaire,
était vu comme l'empire du mal.
Le lui dire en personne,
des décennies plus tard...
sert à rappeler que l'histoire
de 72 va bien au-delà de
la patinoire. Et c'est une
des facettes que veut explorer
le documentaire de Robbie Hart.
- C'est le lien entre la Russie
et le Canada, c'est le lien
le plus organique.
C'est un ADN partagé.
Maintenant, les portes sont
ouvertes à cause de 72, pour moi
aujourd'hui, 50 ans plus tard.
- En pleine pandémie.
- En pleine pandémie!
Puis en pleine tension
entre les deux pays en plus!
- Assis autour d'un verre
comme s'ils étaient en famille,
joueurs de hockey et diplomates
canadiens discutent
des possibilités de
retrouvailles pour fêter
en grand le 50e anniversaire.
Dans le contexte de relations
diplomatiques glaciales,
Gary Smith croit que le Hockey
peut encore faire des miracles.
Il reste un an pour préparer
le terrain. En attendant,
le documentaire sera prêt,
un hommage aux légendes
et à la diplomatie du